meanwhile more breaking news this
afternoon this is in North Las Vegas
early this morning a driver was shot and
killed by police there near Allen and
lamadre as you see on the map there that
is just about north of Lone Mountain
Lauren negretti explains what happened
beforehand
North Las Vegas Police say this all
happened during a traffic stop here in
the area around 1am investigators say
the officers pulled the driver over were
questioning him and then they say he
reached for a gun the officers fired
their weapons it's not known at this
time what the exact interaction was
between the officers and the driver I
spoke to neighbors they were shocked by
this kind of surprises you Sam flowers
is a crossing guard at la Madre and
Allen he could not do his job this
morning due to the police activity in
the area it's a nice corner I do about
six kids in the morning about 10 in the
afternoon and it's it's always been a
nice quiet area when you see something
like this happens it kind of kind of
catches You by surprise the two officers
are on paid administrative leave this is
an ongoing investigation reporting in
North Las Vegas Lauren negretti 8 News
Now